a lot of people look at the red carpet
experience and if they haven't
experienced it which many people haven't
they think oh that would be so amazing
that would be the epitome of glamour
wouldn't it be wonderful but it's not
really like that no it's like the most
shame inducing you literally the inner
dialogue is something like why did I
bother everything I've done in my life
brought me to this terrible moment why
am I here I'm a bad person I shouldn't
have worn this I need to do better like
you I'm ugly like every bad thought
comes into your head and it's like a
shame inducing situation what happens is
it's everything is so heightened in my
opinion it's so heightened that you have
and you have some of the most famous
people in the world most beautiful
people in the world being dressed the
most beautifully and then you know you
walk out there and it's very human for
people to think well they all belong
here but I don't and yeah no one's
thinking that about you but you were
thinking that well I think that many
people looking at you you inevitably
think there must be something on my face
they're laughing at me like it it just
doesn't it doesn't compute with the
nervous system right in any way shape or
form I got on the carpet and Ariana
Grande walks at the same time and I
swear to God they took like one picture
of me and then they were like lady in
the pink
please move right we need to get this
Ariana Grande it feels awkward it is
extraordinary and wonderful and exciting
and you get dressed up but it's also
it's a weird one the first time I went
to a red carpet I was coming through the
red carpet and I paused and I thought
someone was taking my picture and then
he yelled move you're blocking a
celebrity I know you're your insides
it's so weird and it's such a like
unique dumb problem yeah yeah but it's
hard to walk on a red carpet right right
exactly no no and at the same time you
feel like if you complain about it you
can't complain about it and it is kind
of cool and strange but it does feel
like a freak you know yeah you make a
joke of it and then you keep it moving
and you're thankful for your Michael
Kors dress yeah
you